- "ADAM 'DWAYNE THE ROCK
ROOMMATE DEMAMP'"?
ALL RIGHT.
AAH, I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY.
- WHOA, NO, NO, NO.
I AM SO SORRY.
I WAS NOT EXPECTING ANYBODY.
- IT'S MOVE-IN DAY.
- OH, WOW, OKAY.
POINTING FINGERS ALREADY.
NOT A GOOD START
TO OUR RELATIONSHIP.
HOPE YOU DON'T MIND,
I ALREADY KINDA
LAID CLAIM TO THIS SQUADRENT.
- THAT'S GREAT,
'CAUSE I GOT THE MICROWAVE,
AND I'LL JUST
PUT IT THERE, SO--
- SICK. I LOVE POPCORN, SO--
[knock on door]
- HEY. GREETINGS, EARTHLINGS.
ANDERS HOLMVIK,
RESIDENT ADVISOR.
- HI, I'M BLAKE.
- BLAKE.
- WHAT'S UP? I'M ADAM.
DEMAMP.
- UH, YOU PLAY SPORTS.
- SWIM TEAM.
- SO NO?
- [laughs]
SORRY, THAT WAS--
THAT WAS A FUNNY ONE.
- OH, YEAH? THAT'S FUNNY?
YOU KNOW WHAT'S NOT FUNNY?
BURNING ALIVE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
YOUR MICROWAVE
JUST CAUGHT ON FIRE.
MICROWAVES, NOT ALLOWED
IN THE DORM.
SO I'LL BE TAKING THIS,
BECAUSE I'M YOUR R.A.
- HEY, NO,
I DIDN'T MEAN ALL THAT.
COME ON, MAN,
JUST GIMME A BREAK.
- THERE ARE NO BREAKS
IN COLLEGE!
OH, HEY, HEY, HEY!
CUT IT OUT! PULL THOSE UP!
- I'M SORRY, I WAS
SO CLOSE TO FINISHING
WHEN YOU CAME IN,
INITIALLY.
- YOU'RE LUCKY
I DON'T WRITE YOU UP.
ALL RIGHT, YOU TWO ARE
ON MY S-[bleep]-[bleep]-T LIST.
AND IT'S A SHORT LIST.
IT'S TOO LONG.
T-O-O LONG.
WELCOME TO COLLEGE.
- BUT THAT'S MY MICROWAVE!
- GREETINGS, EARTHLINGS.
ANDERS HOLMVIK,
RESIDENT ADVISOR.